now this is just a stunning story
democratic chicago mayor lori lightfoot
she's catching heat for apparently
deciding to only grant interviews to
black or brown journalists
several local chicago reporters are
raising the issue and now mayor
lightfoot herself
is stating in a series of tweets quote
it's a shame that in 2021 the city hall
press corps is overwhelmingly
white in a city where more than half of
the city identifies as black
latino aapi or native american
diversity and inclusion is imperative
across all institutions including media
in order to progress we must change this
is exactly why
i'm being intentionable intentional
about prioritizing media requests
joining me now is the host of the cut
the bull podcast
wilfred riley uh wilford thank you so
much for being here i don't know whether
to ask you whether or not this is
unconstitutional or just simply immoral
what is this this is
something we have never seen well
i think it's obviously very unusual for
a powerful elected official to say
openly that they're only taking media
interviews
from reporters with one racial
background i mean and a lot of stuff
that's being built as i think lightfoot
is billing this is anti-racist
actually seems very disturbingly
neo-racist it seems like we're returning
to a focus on race
almost everywhere um obviously unusual
can't see this as a good thing i also
have some practical questions a la you
know i'm from chicago
that's a very diverse city what counts
as white
would an armenian guy qualify an
arab-american person italian chicago guy
questions remain but i'm surprised by
the move and hope she moves on from it
really really good questions and i like
how you
phrase that this is neo-racism i want to
get to a second story with you in just
one moment but where is this heading
wilfred where is this taking us this
neo-racism it appears to be taking us
back to a time where we
inherently are supposed to embrace
tribes based upon
our very shallow differences based upon
our skin color is that what we're doing
we're going back to a time
of tribalism well frankly i think a lot
of this is just going to be taking us to
court i mean the huge
majority of white and black americans
are fans of that civil rights act of
1964 which prohibits
almost all discrimination on the basis
of race so i don't see how
once they're out in the light of day
things like this from white or from
black or
officials of any other color can survive
i really don't well i actually might
have the perfect story to transition
then
that might put that to a little bit of a
challenge wilfred here's this this is
from
google docs they are now offering pc
alternatives for quote
non-inclusive words so let me give you
some examples mailman
will now be male person crazy baffling
dummy variable equals placeholder
variable
they are essentially taking political
correctness and wokism
into autocorrect into google docs
no more gendered language making
everything as
absolutely bland generic in
honestly non-understandable unders
completely
vague as can possibly be and here's what
i want to ask you about this idea that
you said
it will ultimately not be embraced
you're absolutely right
this isn't when you look at polls this
woke craziness it's not
popular it's these are kind of
propositions adopted by something like
five percent of the population
but they are also the five percent
that's absolutely driving public
discourse
yeah i i think that's correct i mean a
substantial overlap between that and
something i recently read which is
that only 20 percent of the u.s
population or so is on twitter
about a tenth of those people produce
almost all of the viral tweets this is a
niche subset of society
the problem is that it's a niche subset
composed in large part of the
the techies the elite um again however i
don't think the vast majority of people
if this is an optional package are going
to add
woke autocorrect to microsoft word all i
can say is that i think when this
reaches
out to the the 47 states beyond the
beltway
bosnia wash i hope what we see is
laughter instead of an extremely intense
backlash which some in my field worry
about
i don't know if laughter will do it but
there definitely has to be some backlash
to this insanity that is sweeping the
nation
wilfred i appreciate your time with us
tonight
your use of insanity that was very
triggering oh
dear you're absolutely right how dare i
thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else